we're asked to factor 20 u squared V
minus 10 u V squared when they say
factor a binomial like this an
expression that has two terms like this
they really mean break it up into the
product of well one or more terms so
let's see if we can do that and the
easiest way we can do that is say hey is
there any common factor in particular
let's find the greatest common factor of
each of these terms and then divide that
out or you can almost imagine
undistribute it out and I'll show you
what I'm talking about in a second so
what's an eventual you'll be able to do
this in your head but we'll work through
it step by step right now so what is 20
u squared V if we factor it out 20 u
squared V if we do into the prime
factorization it is 20 is 2 times 2
times 5 right that's 2 times 10 that's
20 u squared is times u times u and then
V is just 1 V so we just rewrote 20 u
squared V into kind of a product of its
smallest components its most fundamental
components prime numbers and just use
Envy's now let's do the same exact thing
for the 10 u v squared so we'll put that
minus sign there so that we haven't
fundamentally changed the expression 10
is if we break it down into its prime
factors 2 times 5 then we have 1u x 1u
times V times V that's what V squared is
times V times V now what's the greatest
common factor of these two terms right
here well let's see they both have one
two they both have one two right there
maybe I'll circle that one I could have
circle that one they both have one five
that's one five one five they both have
won you won you there one you there this
one has two but only this one has one
and they both have at least one V they
both have at least one V so they both
have one V so the greatest common factor
is 2 times 5 times u times V so I could
rewrite this expression I can kind of
undistribute the 2 times 5 times u times
V and what will we get if we wrote 2
times 5 times u times V and we say
that's going to be this expression is
equal to this times what
well if you factor the two times five
times u times V out all you're going to
be left with in this first term is the
two times u the two times u here so two
you here and in the second term all
you're going to be left with is a V
right all of this other stuff gets
factored out all you're going to be left
with is a V and hopefully you see if I
multiply two times five times u times V
times to you I'm going to get this first
term here so if I were to distribute it
I would get this first term and if I
multiply two times five times u times V
times this V over here I'm going to get
this second term so this expression and
that expression is the exact same thing
we have factored it out now we can
simplify a little bit two times five
times u times V we can rewrite as ten UV
and then inside the parentheses we of
course have a 2 u 2 u and then a minus V
and we're done we have factored the
expression now you won't be doing it
into this granular level but this is
what we this is the way the best way to
think about it eventually going to say
hey wait look the largest number that
divides both of these is a 10 because
you can say 10 goes into 20 10 goes into
10 and let's say u goes into both of
these and a V goes into both of these so
let me factor out a 10 UV and then if I
divide this thing by 10 UV I'm going to
be left with two you and if I divide
this by 10 UV I'm going to just be left
with a V so that's another way to think
about let me do that right now so we
could say that this is the same thing
another way of approaching it you could
have said that this is the same thing as
well the largest number that divides
both of these is 10 UV 10 UV and that's
going to be times 20 u squared 20 u
squared V over 10 10 u v minus this
thing 10 u V squared over 10 UV this
expression and this are obviously the
same thing if our distribute the 10 UV
would cancel out with each of these in
the denominator right there so there's
the same thing what we can do is we can
simplify this we could say that 20
divided by 10 is just 2 u squared
divided by u
is just a you V divided by V is just one
10/10 is one u divided by U as u V
squared divided by V is just V to the
first power so you're left with 10 u v
times the quantity 2 u minus V either
way you get the same answer